so over the years Marvel has had some
very interesting comic-book characters
they have had some characters there
simply make us ask why in god's name
would they make this character and in
this video I don't know why the hell I'm
doing this in this video we're going to
be talking about one of those characters
today we're going to be discussing the
unbeatable Squirrel Girl
so initially appearing in Marvel
superheroes volume 2 issue number 8 in
1992 Squirrel Girl was a creation of a
man named will Murray then as far as
will Murray and Steve Ditko who had
co-created a Squirrel Girl were
concerned a lot of the comics in the
1990s are really starting to move
towards a darker edge and we saw that
with a lot of the x-men stories things
that would lead up to the Age of
Apocalypse in 1995 and so what they
wanted to do was effectively go back to
an age when comic books were less dark
they wanted to create a more upbeat and
kind of a fun character now squirrel as
she's first brought to us meets up with
Iron Man but what Iron Man is doing here
is he's basically testing the new radar
and his armor that allows him to
basically see without seeing that is to
say the radar will tell him whether or
not he's colliding with anything so for
some reason he loses the ability to see
that he's his armor and his suit can
still function the way it's supposed to
and so what happens as he's traveling
through this forest is that he's being
watched by a woman who has the
attributes of a squirrel and so what she
does is she pounces on Iron Man and the
whole reason for this her logic is that
she simply wanted to demonstrate to Iron
Man that she was capable of sneaking up
on him that she was capable of I guess
demonstrating this she would be a
formidable person and so what she does
here when Tony Sarg asks who she is is
she introduces herself as Squirrel Girl
now what she also does is give us the
sort of explanation about who she is
what she's capable of and how it is she
got her abilities but it's very kind of
brief is very just kind of thrown in
there the way that a will Maria Steve
Ditko do this what they basically tell
us here is that she's a mutant as she's
somewhere along the line developed
mutant powers it allowed her to speak to
squirrels but that she also has the
ability to I guess the agility of a
squirrel in the sense that she's very
very nimble she can move around quite
well and of course she also has various
other attributes including a tail as
well as a cause of she's fashioned for
herself that allow her to have the kind
of I guess maybe sharp appendages that
squirrels normally do but she also goes
as far as to say that she didn't
countered another person as well and
when she goes on to describe this person
is a purr as an individual wearing green
that we ultimately learned this person
was Doctor Doom and so what happens the
Doctor Doom appears for the purpose of
capturing
Tony Stark now we don't really know
exactly why it is that he's decided to
single out Tony Stark and I would go as
far as to say this is really just a
function of the plot what we learn is
that dr. doom intends to throw Tony
Stark out into the water to basically
just sink him and presumably leave him
for dead
now again we know that Tony Stark could
probably escape this circumstance which
is why I say it doesn't really make a
whole lot of sense but what happens here
is that dr. doom takes the bodies of
Tony Stark and Squirrel Girl onto a ship
now the big mistake that Doctor Doom
makes here is that because Squirrel Girl
is effectively can talk to squirrels it
has some kinds of claws he doesn't
really take her seriously doesn't really
think she matters that much and so what
we find is that Tony Stark is
effectively stuck onto the ship he's
being held captive but squirrel girl can
still move around she can still function
here and so what she does is she calls
to the air vents for various squirrels
then as the ships passing over a forest
the core of this will seem to respond
and they answer her call and so what
happens is these squirrels begin
attacking the ship in masse what they
also do is they directly attack dr. doom
and this is what makes what made
Squirrel Girl an instant hit among a lot
of comic book fans because what we find
is the dr. doom shouts out one of the
most famous phrases in the history of
comic books when he says confound these
wretched rodents for every one I fling
away a dozen more of XP basically
telling us the dr. doom is being
overwhelmed by squirrels and this is
absolutely ridiculous and so what
happens is that dr. doom realizing that
he cannot escape the overwhelming power
of squirrel girl and her squirrels
eventually abandons the ship he simply
just jumps away and so what he does is
he jumps into the water and begins
burrowing away to try to get away as
fast as he can but as a result his mask
is left behind which is the only thing
that that Iron Man is able to capture
and so what we find is that when the
story comes to an end the while swore
girl is still being rebuked by Iron Man
while of course he continues to say that
she's simply just too young to be part
of the Avengers what he does say is that
he will basically put in a good word for
her with Captain America so that when
the time comes and she gets older that
she'll be able to join The Avengers
proper
so following squirrel girls initial
appearance and Marvel superheroes she
really just kind of takes a backseat
after this in fact her character won't
really make any kind of appearances in
Marvel Comics until over ten years later
now this comes about around 2004 2005 or
so when she's written into the Great
Lakes Avengers by Dan Slott and the
whole reason for this is because the
Great Lakes Avengers were basically it
was basically a team that was composed
of some pretty useless people it was
really just a way for them to inject
remodel to inject some kind of comedy
into the otherwise very serious tones of
the x-men of the the New Avengers of the
of the Avengers proper and so what we
find is that squirrel girl makes her
debut and issue number two of the four
issue limited series of the Great Lakes
Avengers now again this isn't
necessarily the only volume of Great
Lakes Avengers the Great Lakes Avengers
had existed for quite some time it has
simply weren't that prominent among the
Marvel roster but with the 40s you
limited series which he did appear in
issue number two she was inducted into
the group of the Great Lakes Avengers
but this was really more out of a sign
of desperation than it was for anything
else because the Great Lakes Avengers
really couldn't find anybody else to
join their ranks they had enlisted
various people like I guess like Luke
Cage and and so on and all of them
turned them down then so with Squirrel
Girl becoming a part of the members of
the Great Lakes Avengers she lasted for
about three issues or so now this
follows into the 2005 Christmas special
for the Great Lakes Avengers and this is
where Marvel really capitalized on the
the initial appearance of score girl
when she had defeated Doctor Doom with
her two feet of dr. doom and her initial
appearance it became this kind of
running joke for schoolgirl it became
this kind of thing where score girl was
apparently unbeatable as she could
defeat anybody and so during the
Christmas special we saw her defeat
MODOK for example when MODOK was
basically wreaking havoc and no-one none
of the shield agents were able to
overpower him and so when they had
realized that a scroller was on the way
of course dum-dum Dugan had said thank
God because world ro was going to be the
one to save them all and she was
successful in doing this because what
she had done was she threw one of her
squirrels at the face of MODOK but
because Murdock's head was so large and
his arms were so short he couldn't
afford it and so the squirrel just began
lashing in his face and so as a result
MODOK was defeated when the squirrel man
to enter the body of MODOK and begin
began chewing away at the various I
guess components and cables that had
kept him alive and so from here what we
do is we again pick up with her
character as she has apparently defeated
Thanos now the defeat of Thanos is one
of the most prominent aspects of
Squirrel Girl but this actually happens
off panel we don't see how it is that
this happens what we do is we simply
just pick up with the defeat of Thanos
when The Watcher is talking to her about
what it is this happened and he confirms
that this version of Thanos is not a
robot that it's not any kind of a clone
that it is in fact the real fan o is
telling us yet again that squirrel has
managed to defeat someone that can't
easily be defeated by some of the most
prominent superheroes on the planet
Earth and so what we do is we pick up
with Squirrel Girl during Civil War and
this again was just really a way for
Marvel to acknowledge the fact that
Squirrel Girl is still in existence that
she still does her own thing and with
civil war what we had seen was that with
cable and Deadpool issue number 30 I
believe that of course as we had talked
about our Civil War videos a cable I'm
sorry the Deadpool was looking for a way
to prove himself as being a valuable
member for the pro superhero movement or
pro registration movement and so what
are you done is he had ambushed the
Great Lakes Avengers and when he had
ambushed the Great Lakes Avengers among
the people he had fought were Squirrel
Girl and while everybody else had been
defeated Squirrel Girl was able to
defeat Deadpool in the way she had done
this was by scratching him with little
paper cuts cuts that were so small that
his healing factor didn't register them
and so as a result his body didn't heal
and so we simply just laid there and
started bleeding until until shield
forces were able to arrive and take him
into custody and this seems to be the
way the Squirrel Girl was able to defeat
her various nemesis by simply just
scratching them to death or the very
least seeking a bunch of squirrels on
them so that the squirrels would
overpower them and this again is a
recurring theme that we see and New
Avengers issue number 15 what we also
learned is that apparently her and
Wolverine had had some kind of a
relationship in the past now this is not
overtly given to us this is simply an
instance where by Wolverine is engaging
in I guess in some kind of physical
combat with Danny Rand as a way to
basically keep his skills up to keep his
skills honed and win Squirrel Girl steps
into the fray that a Squirrel Girl and
Wolverine have this kind of banter back
and forth where Wolverine sets us just
like old times
and schoolgirl says that that will rain
seems to perceive their old times
differently than she does again really
kind of pointing to the idea that they
had some kind of involvement in the past
but for the most part this is how
Squirrel Girl functions now because of
the popularity of squirrel girl because
her popularity simply couldn't be denied
by Marvel in relation to how many fans
loved her character what we see is that
in 2014 that model had basically
launched her solo series this is the
first time that Squirrel Girl is
actually actually ever had a solo series
of her own but what's interesting here
is that unlike deadpool squirrel has
more of a niche following she has more
of a cult following whereas Deadpool is
a character who's popular among the
masses everybody knows who Deadpool is
he's a comedic character he's funny he
breaks the fourth wall the squirrel girl
is really more of a character who is
just kind of confined to this smaller
group of fans but the fan base is
ever-growing for her character which I
would imagine would lead her to him to
having more and more prominent roles in
the Marvel continuity with that being
said we're gonna go ahead bring this
video to an end hope you guys enjoyed it
if you did let me know and I will catch
you guys later
peace be sure to follow me on Twitter
there you can keep up with all the
updates from comics explained and talk
to me directly